most discipline is hidden discipline
designed not to liberate but to limit do
not ask why be cautious with how why
leads inexorably to paradox how traps
you in a universe of cause and effect
both deny the infinite
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
heretics of doon is the fifth novel in
Frank Herbert's original doomed series
the book follows the machinations of the
Bene Gesserit sisterhood as they
encounter new powers within the old
Empire the lost ones returning out of
the great scattering after the death of
the worm god-emperor approximately 1500
years ago the fish speakers his female
military force had taken control of the
god Emperor's enormous wealth of spice
they had squandered that tremendous
wealth in petty squabbles and foolish
actions no single event significant
enough to be recorded by history
eventually the play lacks ooh that
friend world at the edge of the Empire
who had produced countless goals for the
god emperor discovered a way to produce
spice melange from within their axolotl
tanks this pushed the fish speakers into
an alliance with the xes
control of Arrakis past to the
priesthood who led a new religion formed
from the remnants of Latos old design
they worshipped the god of the desert
shai elude each worm now containing a
piece of the god emperor's consciousness
still the Bene Gesserit remained one of
the most powerful forces in the empire
superior to the modern fish speaker
council which had inherited the heart of
the old eternities empire they were
superior to chome by far and equal to
the spacing guild though the guilds
monopoly on space travel had long been
broken by the ex Ian's who had invented
technology which allowed vessels to
travel without the use of a guild
navigator the bene Jesuit had always
seen themselves as permanent
revolutionaries it was a revolution that
had been dampened only in the
of the tyrant later the second dampened
but not diverted or stopped since the
time of the god Emperor the Bene
Gesserit sisterhood had purchased 12
duncan idaho golus from that's laylax
ooo up until this point each one had
been assassinated they suspected by the
trail Axew themselves many in the
sisterhood feared this gola project the
Mother Superior terraza knows there are
heretics among them the word heretic
here referred to a private joke within
the sisterhood they were supposed to
follow the orders of the Mother Superior
always with absolute devotion the
sisters did do this except when they
disagreed the most recent duncan idaho
gula was sent to the planet gamoo to be
trained gamoo had once been known as GD
prime until the name was changed by
gurney Halleck the venn a Jesuit keep on
gamoo was watched over by the Reverend
Mother strong you Shuang you was a
heretic the older woman like some others
in the sisterhood believed the goal of
Project to be ultimately dangerous to
the many Jesuit those in her camp of
thought believed that there was a chance
that by meddling what the forces set in
motion by the tyrant they could make the
same mistake as before losing control of
a quiz that's had Iraq to meddle with
the worm bound room nents of the tyrant
that was dangerous in the extreme
terraza does not trust wrong you with
the gola she knows that Shuang you is an
active opposition to the gola project
and has underlying violent motives
against Duncan when the gola was six his
military training on gamoo begin his
instruction was given over to the hands
of the bashar miles tank he was in a
tradies descendant born of a mini Jesuit
Reverend Mother
Myo Stags mother had also been a heretic
giving tag secret knowledge he was not
meant to possess this goal the project
was extremely important to Mother
Superior to Raza she had summoned miles
tang out of her
mint and as a man who had served the
sisterhood his entire life he could not
deny her except for his age 296 standard
years miles Tang was the spitting image
of the original Duke Leto this of course
was part of the bene Jesuit design
terraza intended to use him to
eventually awaken the goal of past
memories as hate had done in the book
dune Messiah this new Duncan gola had
been altered by the talaxian his
reflexes and nerves modernized The
Sisterhood did not deny the possibility
that the play Lex who may have changed
him in other ways as well
still the bene Jesuit gave him the most
careful prana Bindu training at all
stages when Duncan is around 10 years
old
Reverend Mother Lucilla and in printer
is sent to train him at the keep on
gamoo Lucilla was obedient to terrassa
her task would be to teach Duncan Idaho
love in all forms Lucilla was also of a
tradies descent of a particularly
motherly line as a descendant of ciona
she was immune to all forms of
prescience
she was young but had already produced
three children for the sisterhood
when she first speaks with Shuang yuan
gamoo she consents Wang Yue is violent
intent against the gola the jessica
persona within her memories also can
sense doom surely no one believes
Tuscola can become another kwisatz
haderach Lucilla objected Shuang you
merely shrugged Lucilla held herself
quite still thinking was it possible the
gola could be transformed into a male
version of a reverend mother could this
Duncan Idaho learn to look inward were
no Reverend mother dared on the planet
Arrakis formerly known as Arrakis the
priesthood has made a discovery a child
of eight named Gianna broom who has
power over the Great worms of
desert when her village was attacked by
a worm killing everyone she knew she
encountered the creature discovering her
strange gift rage and wild desperation
begin to fill shyona
mindlessly she raced down the doom torch
shaytan coming up behind the worm as it
turned back through the dry place where
it had entered the village without a
thought she dashed along beside the tale
scrambled on to it and ran forward along
the great ridged back at the hump behind
its mount she crouched and beat her fist
against the unyielding surface the worm
stopped the worm had brought she honor
out of the desert and to the City of
King once called Arrakeen the priesthood
had seen her arrival worm riding had
been outlawed by the priesthood but she
Anna did not use maker hooks as did the
Freeman of old the worm carried her of
its own volition some of the priests
called she Anna the child of Shai allude
some believed she should be punished for
mounting Shia loom all her life she Anna
had been taught to despise these priests
and why shouldn't she
they were the oppressive dictators of
her planet for days the priests argued
over the fate of shayana and finally
they decided to test her normally this
test would be an execution in disguise
those who displeased the priesthood
would be dropped into the desert a
thumper would be placed and a worm
summoned they would meet the judgment of
God two worms came for she Anna during
the test as the priest watched from
doctors above her go ahead eat me that's
what they want the priests overhead
could not hear her words but the gesture
was visible and they could see that she
was talking to the two worms of God the
finger pointing up at them did not bode
well
the worms did not move Chiana lowered
her hand you killed my mother and father
and all my friends she accused she took
a step board and shook a fist at them
the worms retreated keeping their
distance if you don't want me go back
where you came from
she waved them away toward the desert
obediently they backed farther and
turned in unison
chiana's power over the great worms
could no longer be doubted by anyone she
is brought to the temple of the
priesthood where she lives like royalty
for six years as the priests study her
and her conversations with her father
the god of the desert the high priest -
it grows fond of the child and even
gives up his own bedchamber to her her
every whim is sated any requests no
matter how difficult must be fulfilled
for the Holy Child the people of Arrakis
eventually begin to worship Chiana
seeing her as a woman of the people all
the while the binning Jesuit have had
their spies keeping a close watch on
Chiana they have plans for her lato ii
himself had predicted the coming of this
child there is a female child named
Chiana brew gan raucous strong you said
she can control the giant worms Lucilla
concealed her alertness giant worms not
shy allude not shy 10 giant worms the
sand writer predicted by the tyrant had
appeared at last the Mother Superior
terraza has commanded Reverend mother
Dario trade to go to Rakus to prepare
shayana for what must come
odhh raid was also an Atreides
descendant strikingly similar in
appearance to her cousin Lucilla old
raid was more similar in age to terraza
however the two of them had bonded at a
young age while at the many Jesuit
schools out of necessity
owed raid was hidden as a child
her mother had made the mistake of being
recognized while breeding and owed raid
was kept with a man and woman who acted
as her true parents until one day The
Sisterhood came for her the memory of
that day still haunted Oh trade when the
Reverend mother's came the foster mother
had not fought the removal of her child
- Reverend mothers came with a
contingent of male and female Proctor's
afterward Oh trade was a long time
understanding the significance of that
wrenching moment the woman had known in
her heart that the day of parting would
come only a matter of time still as the
day's became years almost six standard
of years the woman had dared to hope
then the Reverend mother's came with
their burly attendants they had merely
been waiting until it was safe until
they were sure no hunters knew this was
a Binnie Jesuit planned a trade is sion
o trade saw a great deal of money passed
to the foster mother the woman threw the
money on the floor but no voice was
raised in objection the adults in the
scene knew where the power lay calling
up those compressed emotions Oh trade
could still see the woman take herself
to a straight back chair beside the
window onto the street there to hug
herself and rock back and forth back and
forth not a sound from her the Reverend
mother's used voice and their
considerable wiles plus the smoke of
drugging herbs and their overpowering
presence to lure Oh trade into their
waiting groundcar it will be just for a
little while
your real mother sent us Oh draids since
the lies but curiosity compelled my real
mother her last view of the woman who
had been her only known female parent
was of that figure at the window rocking
back and forth a look of misery on her
face arms wrapped around her self
odhh raid was taught later by the
sisterhood to remember that woman's pain
it was her love for ODE raid that caused
her that misery the sisterhood
understood that love was one of the most
dangerous forces in the universe and was
best avoided thousands of years ago the
lady Jessica's love for Duke Leto had
led to 4000 years of subjugation under
the tyrant Oh Dre decided early on that
she must not love this child she Anna
love would weaken her old raid possessed
the Atreides wild talent terraza new
prescient presence made the Mother
Superior uncomfortable too of old raves
19 offspring produced for the sisterhood
had been quietly put to death they had
been abominations Freeborn like the
tyrant and his sister Dyneema had been
as mooood Eve's sister alia had been on
gamoo Duncan now 15 is nearing the
appropriate age for Lucilla's final
imprint ation sexual imprint ation
throughout his years on gamoo he had
been given access to all the knowledge
of the sisterhood only knowledge of the
Arcana was forbidden to him when he had
learned of the god Emperor he had
wondered what had driven a man to do
such a thing he wishes that he could
have served the god emperor in his time
Duncan had grown to hate the Reverend
mother Shuang you he could sense her
lies and manipulation he resented the
sisterhood now but loved Lucilla just as
the mother superior terraza had intended
one day as Duncan is training at laylax
suface dancer disguised as Myles tag
attacks Duncan and Lucilla after
defeating the face dancer the charmant
at mouths tag quickly discerns that
Shuang you must be involved in the
attack they are no longer safe at the
Bene Gesserit keep on gamoo the three of
them flee into the wilderness along with
the bow
as longtime trusted aide part Hren a
native of gamoo heart Hren leaves them
to create a diversion and is killed by
Swan you heart Rijn however had given
miles tag directions to a secret place
he had discovered many years ago as a
young man an ancient har Conan no globe
there they could hide from those who
would seek them out for four nights tag
leads them through the forest of gamoo
knowing that shuang you would not expect
them to walk he must do the unexpected
as the Mother Superior terraza had
commanded according to he impart wrens
plan everything would indicate that they
went through the wilderness and escaped
the planet on a no ship the ancient no
globe they arrived at was still
functioning
there was water and food miles knows
that he must protect the gola
he comes to the decision that he will
awaken the goal as memories before
Lucilla can complete the final imprint a
ssin upon him this was the only way
according to his mint at projections
that Duncan's safety and sanity would
remain intact tag knows it will be no
easy thing to thwart a full Reverend
Mother on Rakus the temple is attacked
and she Anna is nearly killed by a
hunter seeker the bene Jesuits by kupuna
dies saving the now 14 year old girl the
use of shigga wire during the attack
indicated exeunt involvement and The
Sisterhood intended to punish the guild
that lilac sue and the IXY ins for their
respective roles in the attack Chiana is
taken into a draids care when odd raid
becomes aware of the fact that the high
priests men are spying she has them
killed swiftly an agreement is made and
it is decided that she Anna will be
brought to a place removed from the mini
Jesuit keep on Rakus and from the
priests temple they take Gianna to a
place in the city of keen
the place was once a fish speaker center
in the days of the god Emperor it was a
comfortable building cooled by Xen
machinery
Oh dreidel Oudh the priest to have
representatives in the building but
Reverend Mother has walked the halls and
the priest would not intrude were all
draped not allow and she ona would meet
them only as she allowed Gianna takes to
O trade immediately sensing her power
eager for all that she can learned from
the Reverend Mother we have been a long
time waiting for you o draids said we
will not give those fools another
opportunity to lose you the Society of
the Bennets laylax
is divided into two classes face dancers
and the Masters no one from off world
had ever reported seeing a Tleilaxu
female face dancers were supposedly
sterile mules submissive to their
masters in this time till a lakh sue
have developed a new kind of face dancer
they were almost undetectable they could
absorb the memories as well as the form
and persona of a person they had already
placed some of these new face dancers
within the rinks of the IG's Ian's and
the fish speakers the Tulalip Sioux were
now the only secure source of spice
melange for the guild now that they
could produce it in their axolotl tanks
for every milligram of spice harvested
on Rakus the bennett laylax produced
tons woth was the master of masters he
had been brought back countless times
since before the time of Paul Atreides
the play lacks who had maintained the
myth of their own incompetence and
malevolence the Empire had named them
dirty play lacks ooh we are the people
of the yuckiest
he had reminded his counselors only last
night all else is frontier we have
fostered the myth of our own weakness
and evil practices for these millennia
with only one purpose
even the Benin Jesuit belief
that's laylax ooh held a great belief
based on Zen Sunni ism and Sufism
they were extremely pious and
extraordinarily xenophobic no outsider
or ha winda as they called them was
allowed on the planet
they believed that Leto ii had not been
God but the prophet of God wofe meets
with an honored montre aboard a no ship
descendants of till a lakh sue from the
scattering have warned him that these
mantra is born out of the scattering had
the powers of the bene Jesuit witches
and worse the orange eyed honored montre
demanded total subservience of the clay
lakhs ooh
using concealed weapons wofe kills the
MA train and she and her companions are
replaced with face dancers he decides
that the no ship must disappear there
can be no evidence that the ship ever
made it to trial acts the retribution of
the matras could be great after some
time inside the Harkonnen no chamber on
gamoo miles tag decides that it is time
to awaken the Golda's memories as the
Mother Superior had commanded the young
Duncan was eager to know more about his
past life 8 days had gone by in the no
globe
Duncan reacts negatively to the
Harkonnen decor of the place but does
not understand why he hated everything
about the place tag was attempting to
keep Duncan from being alone with
Lucilla which Duncan noticed Lucilla
wonders if the tyrant knew through
presence that they would one day need
this place when they had first entered
the know globe they found 21 skeletons
the ones who had built this place killed
by the harkonnens to preserve the
secrets tag tells Duncan that he has
been preparing him for the intense pain
necessary to restore his memories
Duncan greatly desires to gain past
memories but it was a thing he also
feared he had discovered that he was a
goalie years ago at the Bene gestured
keep on
the library provided the child with the
most basic details golas humans grown
from a cadaver cells in play Lac su
axolotl tanks axolotl tanks ass lilac su
device for reproducing a living human
being from the cells of a cadaver
describe a goal ax he demanded innocent
flesh devoid of its original memories Zi
axolotl tanks Duncan had learned to read
the silences the blank places in what
the people of the key revealed to him
revelation swept over him he knew only
ten and he knew I am a golem late
afternoon in the library all of the
esoteric machinery around him faded into
a sensory background and a ten-year-old
sat silently before a scanner hugging
the knowledge to himself I am a gamma
tag knew that he must create mental and
physical agony within Duncan as
instructed by The Sisterhood he finds
what he must do to be distasteful which
he tells Duncan the Bene Jesuit had told
him the way tags right hand shot out in
a swift arc the open palm cracked
against Duncan's cheek how dead you
disobeyed me left hand out another
rockin slapped how dare you tag
experienced an initial moment of shock
at the speed with which the young Duncan
reacted to his attacks
Ted continued to create deeper and
deeper paying for Duncan each time
making sure Duncan saw his face at the
instant of greatest agony finally Duncan
called out damn you Leto tag knew it was
done Duncan's mind is flooded with new
awareness he even remembers his own
death on Arrakis his gaze remained on
tag did I buy Paul enough time to escape
answer all of his questions truthfully
he escaped now came the testing moment
where had that laylax who acquired the
idaho cells the Sisterhood's test said
they were original but suspicions
remained the play lacks who had done
something of their own to this Cola
his memories could be a valuable clue to
that thing but the harkonnens duncan
said his memory from the keep meshed oh
yes oh yes ha ha a fierce laugh shook
him he sent a roaring victory shout at
the long dead Baron Vladimir Harkonnen
I paid you back baron oh I did it to you
for all the ones you destroyed miles tag
tells Duncan that the sisterhood has
need of him Lucilla appears and sees
that Duncan's memories are awakened tag
knew that she had intended to imprint
the Gola before the awakening of his
memories she threatens miles tag saying
that he better not have complicated her
task of imprinting Duncan finally
realizes what the imprinting is the Bene
jesuit intended to use him as a breeding
stud he thought he would not allow it
Duncan sensed his own violent thoughts
towards Lucilla in his mind's eye he
could see her covered in blood in that
moment he understood that the play lacks
who had done something to him
they had altered him in some way that
silac Sioux have done something to me
something that has not yet been exposed
Duncan husk exactly what we feared it
was Lucilla speaking from the doorway
behind Tegh she advanced within two
paces of Duncan I have been listening
you two are very informative
what have that lilac Sioux done to you
she demanded Duncan spoke with a
flippancy that he did not feel oh great
imprint her if I knew I would tell you
Lucilla knows that tag has greatly
complicated her task but she was no
longer uncomfortable with the invitation
of someone so young Duncan was no longer
a boy but a man with adult memories
later she attempts to complete the
process
but Duncan has made a judgment about the
sisterhood now
he rejects her Lucilla if you touch me
again without my permission I will try
to kill you
I will try so hard that you will very
likely have to kill me she recoiled he
stared into her eyes I am NOT some damn
stud for you witches is that what you
think we want of you nobody has said
what you want of me but your actions are
obvious
he stood poised on the balls of his feet
the unawakened thing within him stirred
and sent his pulse racing Lucilla knows
that he is serious Lucilla is concerned
that she may not be able to complete her
task given to her by the Mother Superior
terraza the many Jesuit have delivered
their standard messages to the guild X
and the trial Axew for their roles in
the attack on Rakus you will be punished
Mother Superior terraza has decided to
meet with the Tleilaxu master wofe
aboard a guild vessel speculating
terraza tells woth that he will not be
able to deal with her the way he had
dealt with the honored Monterrey's
earlier terraza claims that the
sisterhood had intercepted the missing
Matra ship containing the face dancers
it is a lie but he believes it he is
shocked in his mind he curses her and
all the Damned nabob any Jesuit witches
he recognized her power Wafaa did not
try to delude himself about terraza this
woman was far more dangerous than any
honored Marais if he killed terraza she
would be replaced immediately by someone
just as dangerous
someone with every essential piece of
information possessed by the present
Mother Superior we find your new face
dancers very interesting terraza said
wofe grimaced involuntarily yes
far more dangerous than the honoured
montrezl who were not yet even blaming
the Tleilaxu for the loss of an entire
No
[ __ ] waffle is that he could do away
with terraza and the entire sisterhood
sensing potential violence in him
terraza makes a guess she claims that
she knows about his concealed weapons
and his response demonstrated the truth
of her guests woth wanders again if
telepathy was among the many powers of
Binney Jesuit Reverend mother's she
tells him that in exchange for Benny
Jesu access to their axolotl tanks The
Sisterhood will offer Atreides breeding
mothers though she would never give them
true Atreides only clothes - mimics
terraza also discerns something critical
from analyzing Wolf's speech patterns
she realizes that that sleigh lacks ooh
great belief was based in Zen Sunni ISM
and Sufism she knows now that the mini
Jesuit sisterhood can manipulate the
trial Axew through use of the mission
ara protect IVA terraza offers woth an
opportunity to experience the land of
His Prophet inviting him to the Beni
desert keep on Rakus she will use him as
bait in her scheme the significant fact
is this no Benny play lacks female has
ever been seen away from the protection
of their core planets face dancer mules
who simulate females do not count in
this analysis they cannot be breeders
the trail Axew sequester their females
to keep them from our hands this is our
primary deduction it must also be in the
eggs that the tile Xing masters
concealed their most essential secrets
Benny Jesuit analysis archive number X 0
X T M 9 9 0 1 4 back on raucous ode raid
awaits the arrival of the clay Lacs who
master woth she plans to take shayana
along with woth into the desert when he
arrived
thanks to terrazas new discovery
regarding the roots of the trail Axew
great belief she knew how to trap the
clay lacks ooh they would go deep into
the sands beyond watchful eyes and she
would manipulate him by use of the
mission
protect IVA she would force woth to have
a religious experience the chance to
observe at laylax ooh master in a
religious setting would be invaluable
one swath arrives on Rakus he attempts
to spy upon odd raid with the help of
high priest toufic as they discussed the
holy child she onna toufic had allowed
the talaxian master to listen because he
told him he would help get she on a back
Oh Dre tells to except because of the
attack she had sent for miles tag to
reinforce rocky and planetary defenses
to it believes the Benny Jesuit mean to
wrestle control of the planet from him
though tuek had believed that old ray
didn't know about the Tleilaxu listening
she in fact was aware Dre demands the
secret listener woth to be invited to
sit with them wofe was not supposed to
bring faced answers to raucous but he
brought to anyway Oh Dre did not allow
them into the room Oh Dre noticed that
wofe concealed weapons beneath his
sleeves she detected secret motives in
Wafaa
and comes to the realization that woth a
m-- to substitute a face dancer for high
priest to it my lord - ik Oh Drake said
this play lacks su intends to murder us
both wofe attacks and Oh Dre breaks both
of his arms in two quick motions but not
before one of his darts fires killing -
ik instantly wofe had never expected
that there would be such speed and power
in her attacks the two faced dancers
burst into the room but wofe commands
them to leave when Oh Dre threatens to
end him rendering him unconscious she
sets his broken arms she tells him that
her sisters have been listening and that
he was now her ally she uses what she
had learned from terraza about the trial
axes and Sunni beliefs and manipulates
him into agreeing to an alliance making
him feel as though no laylax suit plot
remains hidden from the mini Jesuit
sisterhood a monopoly would force the
guild to buy more Ixia navigation
machines she said you would have the
guild in the jaws of your crusher
waffle lifted his head to glare at her
the movements in agony through his
broken arms and he groaned despite the
pain he studied Oh Dre through almost
lidded eyes did The Witches really
believe that was the extent of the clay
lack Suitland he hardly dared hope the
mini Jesuit were so misled of course
that was not your basic plan Oh Dre said
WAAFs
eyes snapped wide open she was reading
his mind
I am Dishonored he said when you saved
my life you saved a useless thing he
sank back Oh Dre din hailed a deep
breath time to use the results of the
chapter house analysis she leaned close
to woof and whispered in his ear the
shariat needs you yet woof gasps Oh
trade setback that gasp said it all
analysis confirmed the Vinnie Jesuit had
always used religion to manipulate and
control the play lacks ooh master was no
different from the rest the planet
chapter house had been occupied by the
mini Jesuits sisterhood for 1400 years
and even then they only thought of it as
a temporary planet it was a secret world
but of course there was always the risk
of accidental discovery terraza on
chapterhouse
wonders where miles tag and the gola
could be she had instructed the bashar
to act unpredictably but she had not
expected this she has already asked the
flail Axew to prepare a new gola
just as a precaution in case the current
one was dead terraza is conscious of the
fact that the Bene Gesserit sisterhood
could be swallowed up by the honored ma
trace the matras had not returned out of
the scattering because of curiosity but
out of dreams of conquest and they had
begun their conquest the meninges are
keep on gamoo had been attacked
Shuang you had been killed but not
before she left a message to her sisters
swung you left you a message and only we
might read in the where marks on the
furniture Yes Mother Superior and then
she knew she would be attacked and had
time to leave a message
I saw your earlier report on the
devastation of the attack it was quick
and totally overpowering the attackers
did not try to take captives what did
she say
[ __ ] the Binnie Jesuit referred to the
Mott raised as such for a simple reason
they believed that the Mott raised made
a mockery of the sisterhood copying them
yet selling themselves for power the
matras did not have mastery of melange
they used an inadequate substance which
turned their eyes orange instead of the
characteristic blue within blue which
marked spice addiction these matras gain
power through sexual enslavement they
ate some of the many Jesuit ways but
possess none of their deeper awareness
and yet they dared placed themselves at
the center of worship terraza clearly
understood she won't use message the
matras had acted the ones out of the
scattering sought the vinny Jesuit elder
secrets secrets lost to them during
their time away from the old Empire
terraza commands burrs molly who was
trained by tag to go to gamoo in search
of miles tag and the gola with as many
resources as he needs she suspects that
the Golan never left the planet back on
Arrakis owed raid continues with the
plan though she wonders why the gola is
not yet on the planet she takes she Anna
and wafted our ESPA lot the place where
Latos no room had been found they go
into the desert to find a worm owed raid
intends to force woth into a religious
experience and observe him she anna
begins dancing summoning shite an odd
raid looks into the distance and feels
the coming of a vision
a warning she realizes that she is
looking at the place or the one God was
divided the place where Leto the second
had fallen into the Idaho River fifteen
hundred years ago she wonders if the
heretics of The Sisterhood had been
correct what would come out of the
meddling in the remnants of the tyrants
work as the worm approaches owed raid
resigns herself to whatever fate is to
come woth is overcome with religious
exultation a sibilant hiss subterranean
and muted by sand it became louder with
shocking swiftness there was heat in it
a noticeable warming of the breeze that
twisted down their rocky avenue the
hissing swelled to a crescendo roar
abruptly the crystal ring gaping of a
gigantic mouth lifted over the dune
directly above she onna Shaytan Chiana
screamed not breaking the rhythm of her
dance Here I am shy tan as it crested
the dune the worm dipped its mouth
downward toward Chiana san cascaded
around her feet forcing her to stop her
dance the smell of cinnamon filled the
rocky defile the worm stopped above them
Messenger of God wah freed he dried the
perspiration on old raids exposed face
and made the automatic installation of
her still suit puff outward perceptibly
she inhaled deeply sorting the
components behind that cinnamon assault
daintily like a child on unfamiliar
ground the worm once more moved forward
it slid across the dune crest curled
itself down onto the exposed rock and
presented his burning mouth slightly
above and about two paces from shayana
as it stopped Oh Dre became conscious of
the deep furnace rumbling of the worm
she could not tear her gaze away from
the reflections of lamb biet orange
flames within the creature it was a cave
of mysterious fire
Oh Dre did see that she onna commanded
the worm but she could also see that it
was not the girl's words that moved the
creature but something else wa''f k m--
up a side ode raid his translate gaze
fixed on the worm i am here he whispered
ode raised silently cursed him any
unwarranted noise could attract this
beast on to them
she knew what woof was thinking though
no other till Axew had ever stood this
close to a descendant of his prophet not
even the rocky and priest had ever done
this with her right hand Schiano made a
sudden downward gesture down to a
Shaytan she said the worm lowered its
gaping mouth until the internal fire pit
filled the rocky defile in front of them
her voice little more than a whisper she
ona said see how shy cannabase me mother
chode raid could feel she honest control
over the worm a pulse of hidden language
between the child and monster it was
uncanny though odd raid is annoyed by
wofe she knew that never before had one
of the Bene Gesserit had an opportunity
to study at laylax ooh master
religiously the inside she was gathering
was highly valuable the three of them
mounted the worm and Shaytan moves
though she Anna had commanded the
creature she had only been allowed to
ride a worm once before the day shy
elude brought her to the city of King
years ago now the worm moved again of
its own accord towards that place of odd
raids vision members of the priesthood
and the Bene Gesserit followed behind in
Thopter eventually the worm did stop and
when they dismounted it merely returned
into the sands the weight at Cain the
immortal hand of the god Emperor still
moved those creatures in the sand it had
come to this place of its own free will
drawn back toward the place where Leto
sinless stream had begun
the three of them end up falling deep
into a sand slope it is only then that
ode rate realizes the place they had
fallen into an ancient Freeman water
storage basin they were in siege to bore
still gars placed during the time of
Paul Atreides the place where late till
ii had hidden his spice horde the place
had long since been cleaned out Oh Dre
believes that she is the one being
brought here for a purpose using her
knowledge of the mission are protect Eva
Jim manipulates woth into staying behind
while she explores the place she gives
Xian an instruction to keep an eye on
him odhh raid can still since the
warning from her other memories she
finds several desert mummified bodies
that had been stabbed to death in what
looked like ritual killings she knew
that the bodies could not be from the
Fremen times they were from the famine
times and made her fearful owed raid
could still smell the residue of melange
in the place and wanted to turn back but
something compelled her forward she
finds a word carved on the floor rfl she
knows the meaning the cloud darkness at
the end of the universe she realizes
that the god Emperor had reached out of
the past to send her a message written
in ancient Checotah she finds the word
here it leads her to a trapdoor
inside Oh Dre discovers a great treasure
of melange ninety thousand long tons it
was half the year's harvest on the
entire planet of Rakus geniusly hidden
and left there by late to the second for
her to find written on the walls in the
ancient Atreides language were the words
of the god Emperor a Reverend Mother
will read my words something cold
settled in odd raids cuts she moved to
her right with the light ploughing
through an empires ransom in Milan
there was more to the message I
bequeathed to you my fear and loneliness
to you I give the certainty that the
body and soul of the Bennet Jesuit will
meet the same fate as all other bodies
and all other souls another paragraph of
the message beckoned to the right of
this one she plowed through the clawing
melange and stopped to read what is
survival if you do not survive whole ask
the Bennet laylax that what if you no
longer hear the music of life memories
are not enough unless they call you to
noble purpose there was more of it on
the narrow end wall of the long chamber
ode raids stumbled through the melange
and knelt to read
why did your sisterhood not build the
golden path you knew the necessity your
failure condemned me the god Emperor
two millennia of personal despair the
words God Emperor were not written in
Shikoku but in the language of the
islami at where they conveyed an
explicit second meaning to any speaker
of that tongue your God and your Emperor
because you made me so Oh Dre mild
grimly that would drive wofe into a
religious frenzy the higher he went the
easier to shatter his security she did
not doubt the accuracy of the tyrants
accusation nor the potential in his
prediction that the sisterhood could end
the sense of danger had led her to this
place on earring ly something more had
been at work to the worms of Rakus still
moved to the tyrants ancient beat he
might slumber in his endless stream but
monstrous life a pearl in each worm to
remind it carried on as the tired had
predicted what was that he had told the
sisterhood in his own time she recalled
his words when I am gone they must call
me shite an emperor of Gehenna the wheel
must her
and turn along the golden path yes that
was what terraza had meant but don't you
see the common people of Rakus have been
calling him Shaytan for more than a
thousand years
so terraza had known this thing without
ever seeing these words she had known I
see your design terrassa
and I know the burden of fear you have
carried all these years I can feel it
every bit as deeply as you do Oh Dre
knew then that this warning since would
not leave until she ended or The
Sisterhood vanished from existence or
the peril was resolved Oh dreidel if did
her light got to her feet and slog
through the melange to the wide steps
out of this place at the steps she
recoiled more of the tyrants words had
been cut into each riser trembling she
read them as she moved upward to the
opening my words are your past my
questions are simple with whom do you
ally with the self idolaters of laylax
with my fish big of bureaucracy with the
cosmos wandering guild with the
Harkonnen blood sacrifices with a
dogmatic sink of your own creation how
will you meet your end as no more than a
secret society o trade climate
reading them a second time as she went
noble purpose what a fragile thing that
always was and how easily distorted but
the power was there immersed in constant
peril it was all spelled out on the
walls and stairs of that chamber terraza
knew without having it explained the
tyrants meaning was clear join me
as she emerged into the small room
finding a narrow ledge along which she
could swing herself to the door Oh Drake
looked down at the treasure she had
found she shook her head and wonder at
terrazas wisdom so that was how the
sisterhood might end terrazas design was
clear all the pieces in place nothing
certain wealth and power it was all the
same in the end the noble design had
been started and it must be completed
even if that meant the death of the
sisterhood what poor tools we have
chosen that girl waiting back there in
the deep chamber below the desert that
girl and the goal of being prepared on
Rakus I speak your language now old worm
it has no words but I know the heart of
it
o draids all a tous message as a warning
and an invitation The Sisterhood may end
she wonders at the purpose of the vini
Jesuit was survival a sufficient enough
purpose owed raid knows that she must
act on her own they traveled to the
Benham desert sanctuary on raucous and
old raid reveals secret knowledge to
woth the sisterhood planned to plant the
worms of Rakus on countless planets of
the scattering he thought it was a lie
and she had intended him to though it
was true he asked for the real reason
for distinction among the many Jesuit
ranks and she tells him that some fear
that they may birth another quiz that's
had a rack o drain manages to refocus
wast doubts about the sisterhood onto
the people of the scattering she
manipulates him into agreeing to
Alliance one she knows that many in the
sisterhood will not like our survival in
the face of the storm that is brewing
among the scattered ones she said that
laylax uu survival to the farthest thing
from our desires is an inn to those who
preserve the great belief
waaah felt a tight band release itself
from his breast the unexpected the
unthinkable the unbelievable was true
the many Jesuit were not PO in de all
the universe would get follow the
benyclaire lakhs into the true faith God
would not permit otherwise especially
not here on the planet of the Prophet
the effectiveness of the benin Jesuit
mission are protect Eva had proven
itself again back on gamoo miles tech
has made contact with burrs Mali they
have arranged a rendezvous it is snowing
when they finally leave the new globe
heavily armed Lucilla carried only a
single lace gun with one burst the been
a Jesuit believed that it diminished
them to go into battle with much more
than their skills now that they were
outside of the know globe they could be
detected by life scanners they could
hear the sounds of battle in the
distance the ground rumbled they could
hear shouting and voices in the distance
tag recognized face dancers he tells
Lucilla and Duncan to run the attackers
advanced on him he fired at them but
they did not fire back he realized that
they wanted him alive
metallic suit could expend any number of
face dancers to run down his lays guns
charge he attempts to run but he is
stunned and captured Lucilla and Duncan
make it to an armored ground car VIRs
molly leads them out of the car and puts
a life blanket on them to hide them from
detection they are led by burrs mollies
men through the wilderness through a
cleft and into an enclosed passage cut
into the rocks thick algae grew on the
ceiling and the walls of the place it
was specially grown algae that disrupted
life scanners the face dancer Sarita
tells Lucilla that she was bred and
trained to kill the matras Lucilla
trades places with the face dancer to
throw off the searchers she will
disguise herself as an honoured ma tree
Duncan is disguised as a clay Lac su and
the two of them split up taking
different paths
when miles tag wakes he encounters three
strange figures they put a device known
as a T probe on his head a device from
the scattering the pain it caused him
was exquisite as they attempted to
penetrate his mind he wonders if there
is a greater pain he wonders if this is
what the spice agony feels like for
Reverend mothers the captors continue to
increase the pain even more and then
suddenly stillness miles Tegh wonders if
he is dead but he is not the device
takes over his flesh and he feels as
though another person is sharing his
body it was reading his senses trying to
block his awareness it was copying him
tag attempts to counter the probe using
his mentat powers blocking it from
copying his memories but it would have
everything else tagged centered his
focus on the movements of the probe he
found that he could anticipate it now as
if he was growing some new muscle his
captors wonder why they cannot read his
mind and then he forces his eyes open
from his perspective the three are
moving in ultra slow motion in the time
of several eye blinks tank escapes from
confinement killing his captors with
supreme bloody ease he had predicted
their every move using his mentat
abilities tag determines that the agony
of the probe had lifted him to some new
level of ability hidden powers that had
been awaiting within him had been
unlocked out of necessity taking the
form of this strange new kind of
precedence slowly he felt himself
returned to a normal sense of time he
escaped to the outside he knew the place
he was in the city of his eye he was
free on the mini Jesuit secret planet
chapter house some sisters are called in
for Au draids death after what she did
on Rakus the vinny Jesuit were still
wary of the Atreides flaws they did not
fully trust their hunger for power which
was evident by their history
the heretics of The Sisterhood believed
that The Sisterhood was playing directly
into the hands of the tile Axew who made
this Duncan Goler for their own purposes
they believed that they will be forced
to serve the tile Axew design which
would be worse than the time of the
tyrant they would be vulnerable and
perhaps even further
considering Latos message perhaps the
goal of Project had never been truly
theirs from the start but instead
something that was set in motion by late
till the second himself late to his
message in siege to war worries terraza
she wonders if the sisterhood is to end
now crushed by invaders from the
scattering terraza decides that she must
go to Rakus and she may have to do what
the others want kill owed raid on gamoo
tag went to appear before an honored ma
Trey as the Bene jesuit bashar he knew
there was danger in the place tag
deduces that the place is a bank the
honored ma Trey that he met was old Tech
had not expected her age she tells him
that if he ever sees her eyes fully
orange then that means that he has
offended her beyond her ability to
tolerate she tells tank the many Jesuit
are no match for the ma Trey's I'm sure
you understand this kind of power
generally Bashar
she said the vintage Ezra trained you
well they are quite talented but not I
fear as talented as we are the old
martyr a summons the Matra who is meant
to mark tag tags since the danger he
determines that he must use his new
talents tag becomes the whirlwind he was
a monstrous threat he made his way
through the complex as a blurred sleep
slaughtering everyone he met as blood
sloshed around him doing so required
minimal mental effort blood splattered
him as he drove himself through the
headquarters building slaughtering
everyone he met
as he had learned from the many Jesuit
teachers the great problem of the human
universe late in how you managed
procreation he could hear the voice of
his first teacher as he carried
destruction through the building you may
think of this only as sexuality but we
prefer the more basic term procreation
it has many facets and offshoots it has
apparently unlimited energy the emotion
called love is only one small aspect
Tegh crushed the throat of a man
standing rigidly in his path and at last
found the control room for the
building's defenses Tech knows that this
transformation had something to do with
his Atreides blood as he ran toward an
alley the people he passed seemed as
still as statues he examined himself and
could see that his blood was black that
moment of ultimate pain and crisis had
forced him into a new domain of human
potential the god Emperor's design he
now possessed a double vision a strange
prescient tag realized that he could
also sense the positions of no ships and
decides that he will capture one his
double vision provided him with the path
lucilla & bers male head to the safe
place to rendezvous with duncan there
they encounter a young woman and Lucilla
immediately knows that something is off
about her the woman named Marbella is an
honored Marais she attempts to Kilmer's
Molly after he tries to slap her she
assumed that Lucilla is a great honored
male because of her clothing and because
of the ease in which Lucilla subdues her
Murr Bella tells Lucilla that she has
subdued Duncan and that she intends to
complete the sexual enslavement of him
during the process however Duncan gains
access to the memories of all the other
Duncan idaho's he is crushed by the
memories he can see his deaths all of
them he remembers the axolotl tanks the
gross living female flesh the Tali laksa
design the hidden thing in him awakens
the secret to destroying the mantra
he overwhelms marbella forcing her to
lose control of her own responses
marbella realizes who duncan is the MA
trays were warned of a gola possessing
of forbidden knowledge gifted by the
Tleilaxu she wanted to kill him but she
could not Lucilla had watched from
another room when she comes in marbella
begs her to kill Duncan
but Lucilla says that Duncan will go to
Rakus on raucous terraza tells odd raid
that the preservation of the sisterhood
is the only important thing Oh Dre tells
terraza that the flail acts who give the
appearance of full cooperation but
something is disturbing her she wonders
if there axolotl tanks are truly tanks
she suggests to terraza that they could
be surrogates living organisms the
remnants of the clay lacks ooh females
no one had ever seen ATS laylax ooh
female it was monstrous Oh Dre tells the
Mother Superior what she has learned of
the MA trace from the trial Axew they
had surpassed the sexual skills of many
Jesuit in printers such as Lucilla
but the honored MA trays employed their
skills in a manner that is ultimately
fatal to themselves and others
Oh draids suggests that the change that
the clay lacks ooh had made to the
Duncan Idaho gola was to make him the
equivalent of a male honored ma Trey
that's why the honored ma Trey's
attacked their keep on gamoo believing
the gold was their terraza realized that
they did not know what this goal of was
and now that he had been reawakened he
was unpredictable the sequencing of the
golus education became shambles even
before they escaped from the gamma keep
he leapt ahead of his teachers to grass
things that were only implied and he did
this at an alarmingly accelerated rate
who knows what he has become by now the
trail Axew meddled with the forces that
had produced their quizzes had a rack
and led to 3,500 years of subjugation
under the tyrant
after meeting shyona terraza determines
that she Anna will be loyal in exchange
for many Jesuit teachings terraza had
been intrigued by the young girl and she
Anna recognized the power of the Mother
Superior I am informed that you may
become one of us terraza said both women
could see the effect of this on the girl
by now Gianna was more fully aware of a
Reverend mother's accomplishments the
powerful beam of truth had been focused
on her she had begun to grasp at the
enormous body of knowledge the
sisterhood had accumulated over the
millennia she had been told about
selective memory transmission about the
workings of other memories about the
spiced agony and here before her stood
the most powerful of all Reverend
mother's one from whom nothing was
hidden terraza and owed raid believed
that one day she Anna could become a
Mother Superior of extraordinary ability
terraza owed raid and she ona and the
bene Jesuit company along with woth and
the high priest ooook who had been
replaced by a face dancer after he was
killed convene at dar s ballot it is a
tense gathering terraza sensed a danger
of violence in the meeting it appears
that the false
toufic had convinced himself that he is
actually to it Walt
is surprised by this and cannot control
him never before had he seen a face
dancer behave in this way
it was the Binnie Jesuit plot this false
- it was now a creature of the
sisterhood and remembered nothing of his
face dancer origins that laylax who had
designed these new faced answers - well
one could only imagine what was
happening with the face dancers the play
lacks who had implanted among the fish
speakers and the Exynos wofe was greatly
intimidated by terraza terraza tells
woth that they will serve the Tleilaxu
but they will never become axolotl tanks
woth was shocked
sisterhood knew even the secret of the
Tleilaxu
axel otto tanks Wafaa attempted to
signal his face dancers to
attack but terraza stops him assuring
him that that's laylax who will fall if
he does not agree woof growls teeth what
was she doing he entertained the Matt
thought that The Sisterhood had clogged
his mind with some secret drug in the
air they knew things denied to others he
stared from terraza to oh drain and back
to terraza he knew he was old with
serial gola resurrections but not old in
the way of the Benny Ches rate these
people were old they seldom looked old
but they were old old beyond anything he
dared imagine wofe has no choice but to
accept Oh Dre tell Fiona that the
honored matras will come to Rakus they
had returned from the scattering because
they see the old Empire as an easy
conquest at the penthouse at Darras a
lot the honored ma Trace attack terraza
sees the beam from the Thopter and
recognizes that her own death is
imminent the beam severs both of her
legs but she manages to cut off the
blood flow from her wounds she reminds
herself that the pain was not as great
as the spiced agony she thinks to
herself I have one owed raid comes to
terraza as she lies dying placing their
foreheads together they share memories
owed raid is now the Mother Superior
owed raid and Shion ahead towards the no
room sometime later tags stolen no ship
arrives on Rakus he has arranged to meet
Chiana anode raid in the desert they
will arrive upon the back of a worm tag
meets with Lucilla aboard the no ship
and tells her that they are there to
pick up owed raid Chiana and a worm he
tells her that he and his people will
remain to create a diversion he knew
that the honored montrezl would destroy
Rakus when they learned that the gola
the secret to their demise was there it
had been terrazas design all along the
gola had been bait when o Dre boards the
no ship she comes to take for quite some
time now she had known that he was her
father
looking at him now she could see that
something had been changed about him
something was different he tells her to
take the ship to chapter house and that
the Golem must go with them too they had
to change terrazas original design he
was no longer just bait for the
destruction of the planet they needed
his talents tag tells burrs Molly that
he will take over as Bashar owed raid
Chiana Duncan Ebers Molly Lucilla and a
single worm escaped the destruction of
the planet Arrakis the honored Matsuri
Marbella is held prisoner woth and his
face dancers died on the planet of the
prophet tag had sacrificed himself so
that the others could escape the honored
montrezl unleashed their obliterator
weapons scorching the surface of the
planet doom killing all life on the
surface the planet of MU Adeeb home of
the zen suni Wanderers where the god
emperor had ruled from for 4000 years
was gone on chapterhouse
o trade adjustment in the sisterhood
would not like that she was the mother
superior many in the sisterhood still
distrusted the Atreides
their history had shown a hunger for
power she knew her position may be
temporary the sisterhood had tested
Chiana she too was a tradies descended
from ciona
and immune from presence the worm they
had captured was nearing metamorphosis
and when the time came they would bathe
it in a mixture of melange and water
converting it into mini sand trout they
would release them onto chapter house
they would create a second do
terraza had wanted the destruction of
Rakus to eliminate almost all worms
according to her they were an Iraq
dealer force which held the universe in
bondage
the worms containing a pearl of Latos
awareness magnified that grasp he did
not predict events but instead he had
created them by the time the worms
returned to their larger numbers
humankind would be far too numerous
doing too many different things
no single force could rule over all of
their futures completely but this was
always his design Marbella and the gola
are being held inside of the notion
Marbella
is pregnant with Duncan's child Duncan
still insists that he will not serve the
sisterhood telling odd raid that he will
never be a stud for them Duncan had
realized some time ago that he had never
fully trusted the witches not even the
lady Jessica owed raid promises to help
Duncan in any ways that she can when he
asked why she responds by saying this
because my ancestors loved you because
my father loved you love you witches
can't fill love she stared down at him
for almost a minute
the bleached hair was growing out dark
at the roots and curling once more into
ringlets especially at his neck she saw
I feel what I feel
she said and your water is ours Duncan
hi-de-ho seeing the effect that these
ancient Freeman words had had on Duncan
Oh Dre turns and leaves the room she
looks upon the worm they had captured
the last pearl of Latos awareness they
had freed him Gianna would be trained as
a been a Jesuit sister and eventually
lead the project to breed new worms on
Shafter House Leto the second the god
Emperor
the tyrant had helped the Bene Gesserit
sisterhood find their noble purpose
10,000 years since Leto began his
metamorphosis from human into the sand
worm of raucous and historian still
argue over his motives was he driven by
the desire for long life he lived more
than 10 times the normal span of 300
standard years but consider the price he
paid
was it the lure of power he is called
the tyrant for good reason but what did
power bring him that a human might want
was he driven to save humankind from
itself
we have only his words about his golden
path to answer this and I cannot accept
the self-serving records of darkest
Pilat might there have been other
gratifications which only his
experiences would illuminate without
better evidence the question is moot
we are reduced to saying only that he
did it the physical fact alone is
undeniable next in this series we will
cover chapter house Doon the final book
in Frank Herbert's original dune saga
chapter house picks up several years
after the events of heretics as The
Sisterhood awaits for young worms to
rise out of the newly formed deserts of
chapter house Duncan Idaho has visions
of a mysterious man and woman who watch
him from some other place consider
supporting this channel on patreon if
you enjoyed the video and please
subscribe for more dune videos and check
out the dune playlist on this channel
for more videos on the lore of the book
series
you
[Music]
you